フェアみんな外したちょうどや僕は前回ちょっと前にですねあの巨大ぐう聖をポンプで
膨らませて爆発させるのはちゃったんですけど
見事失敗したんで今回はそう
リベンジって言うけどね
こちらにだから辛い風船の水ふうせんバージョンを準備しました
なんかなんかペロいでグリーン the 交差9ねーな
ホーストれたりしないのか
あトレイじゃんもう入れて入れると言わんばかりところ感じ
[音楽]
を
ええええええ
やばいやばいプロ強くなってきた
いい
[音楽]
やばいこれはやばいあっ
結構ヤバいんですけど巨ねまぁ前回プレイ birthday なかっただけなんで
もう僕は正直かなり悔しいんですよもう風船みたいなもうすぐ
言われたくなる頂いちゃってます
あずなんで今日はそのねくらい風船に自らを山ピング乗りして
大丈夫ジャンプなりして完璧にブレイブバーストね
今日は綺麗に奇妙と思いますじゃあもうちょっと
爆発寸前に強いんでたまってやっちゃいました a
うぞ
ずぶんで急いで嫌になってきたなぁ
宮崎ますいけますよいきますよ本当に知らねえぞこれやべーぞ
これに値するこれはもう対処これは米ジェジュンとになるいただきます次位
21詰まって3妻じゃねえちょっと待ってましたんで
ええええええウォッチともっとまじかん家に行ってきたん
いやではないけど普通失うものがでかい気がする
水を
シーツーワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
jr
[音楽]
はぁ
ああああああ
第コース第コースちょっと待って待って待って待ったやばいやばいやばい
部屋的なやばい部屋的な病これはこれ部屋的な部屋的な4倍だ
これでも部屋的なやばいやつだ